a portion of this video was sponsored by
Walgreens
[Music]
or exceeded dangerous levels if they
keep this up there's gonna be nothing
holding him back oh no it's too late run
run
um sorry about anti-pad over there he
just escaped from his containment cell
pay him no mind he's kind of a minor
glitch in the system pretty darn
harmless honestly the scariest thing
about him is just how cringy he is
anyway Let's uh let's try that again
shall we hello Internet welcome to film
Theory the show that just wants to ask
have you ever experienced a terrible
occurrence that has impacted you
significantly now if you're a fan of our
sister location Game Theory or spend any
time in the gaming zone of YouTube
you're probably familiar with Sean
McLaughlin AKA jacksepticeye
ladies crosses 10 years on YouTube he's
proven himself time and time again as a
gamer as an entrepreneur as a
philanthropist but recently he's also
been proven himself as a Storyteller
don't get me wrong Sean has never been
shy about hopping into character for one
of his videos
welcome welcome back the good doctor
services are needed yet again where's my
wand you can't be a magician without a
where's my hat
[Music]
but now it appears as though Sean is
something greater planned for those
characters a wider connected universe
that brings them all together to tell a
story of love loss and chaos and it all
begins with one I've been here this
entire time
the powerful and terrifying antiseptic
eye recently Sean released what has got
to be one of his most ambitious projects
to date the iris project an interactive
live stream where the chat used text
commands to cooperatively play a
legitimate video game solving puzzles
and ultimately unlocking all sorts of
new channel more the video itself
follows one specific Sean Character
Chase Brody now to catch you up in case
you don't watch every single one of
jacksepticeye's let's plays Chase is
your typical bro so much so that his
spin-off YouTube series is called bro
average yo what's up guys I'm Chase and
welcome to Pro average but while on
screen chases live in large with
teabagging trick shots off-screen he
appears to be having difficulty with his
family life this one's called I'm
staying at my sister's this weekend well
I don't care what your sister says just
please at least let me see you at the
weekends do this escalates and
ultimately it comes to a climax at the
very end of a 2018 video titled what do
you want from me in which Chase hears
his family screaming he goes to explore
his house only to be confronted by
another of Sean's characters the
unpredictable and violent antiseptic eye
it appears that whatever happened here
ended in tragedy because a year later we
get the video Simply titled Chase in it
we watch as Chase approaches a makeshift
grave and then places a photo of his
family on it they're dead but who's
responsible antisepticeye Chase himself
or something else he begins to drink his
troubles away until he suddenly
teleported to the top of a parking
garage and it's here in an upload coming
three years later that the iris project
begins in Earnest continuing the story
of Chase antisepticeye and presumably
the rest of Sean's personas right now
that narrative is still in its early
stages but it's clear that Sean has big
plans for it moving forward I would
assume the next installment is going to
be coming sometime either next summer or
Halloween based on how he's been
treating these sorts of uploads in the
past but here's the thing you don't need
to wait that long my friends I think
that we've cracked open what the wider
story is in their pursuit of Discovery
and technological growth the iris
Corporation has gotten too ambitious
it's attempted to tap into forces that
are far beyond their control and by
doing this they've Unleashed a force
that threatens the not just Iris not
just Chase in the other personas but all
of humanity so grab your clipboards and
start scribbling away loyal theorists
it's time to dive in because the main
part of this was a live event that's now
unlisted let me just start with a quick
recap of what actually happened in the
iris project so we're all on the same
page the videos from the live stream
that the chat unlocked are framed as
archival footage of a series of
interviews between Chase Brody and an
unnamed Iris scientist I'm just going to
call this random scientist uh a name
that comes to the top of my head uh
let's just say Aaron no real reason for
that anyway at first the interview is
more of an interrogation Aaron seems
distant and cold shots framed so he
don't even see his face he refers to
chase as a subject rather than a person
subject has no recollection of spatial
transition wait excuse me subject
Aaron's questions also seem borderline
nonsensical at first does Chase recall
how he was teleported has he seen or
heard things that weren't actually there
seen objects appearing or disappearing
lost track of time that sort of thing
however as the days of the interrogation
go on and Aaron attempts to warm up to
chase we begin to see his face and his
questions start getting more personal
have you ever experienced a terrible
occurrence that has impacted you
significantly have you ever experienced
a terrible occurrence that has impacted
you've never experienced a terrible
occurrence that has impacted you
significance also it becomes clear that
Chase isn't alone in the facility
there's something else here too
something that wants to talk something
named Echo hello yeah yeah I hear you
who are you Echo are you there multiple
times throughout the week other unseen
entities enter Chase's cell these beings
are what iris classifies as altars and
they speak to chase using what the
camera picks up as some sort of strange
whisper or whale noise we can tell that
at least one of them is tormenting Chase
please please please go away and the
other is telling Chase that he's special
can you get me out of here
I don't understand you mean I'm special
eventually after the chat unlocked all
but one of the Clips in the iris project
live stream the facility changed the
power started flickering on and off
chairs were strewn about red warning
lights blared throughout the building
the facility is in lockdown security
guards enter Chase's room and escort him
out as Chase warns them of the impending
danger that they all face wait we have
to leave I've been here before please
let me go Iris ignores Chase's warning
only to discover
antisepticeye here to once again wreak
havoc on Chase's life oh geez so now
that you're all caught up the way I see
it there are three main Mysteries
presented to us here what's Iris up to
how to chase an anti-play into all of it
and finally who or what is Echo well I
believe we have answers to all three of
those questions today but before we
start decoding what it all means let's
take a moment to talk about our sponsor
for this portion of the video Walgreens
that's right the drugstore that's
literally everywhere noticed little old
Us online and sponsored this episode we
are legit guys this holiday season if
you're looking to keep yourself safe you
don't need to be locked up and isolated
in a dark high security research
facility instead you just make sure that
you're up to date with your vaccinations
and thanks to Walgreens it is easier
than ever to do that most people think
that you have to make a doctor's
appointment wait in line the whole thing
just to get some vaccines but you can
actually have one of walgreens's
specially trained Pharmacy experts do it
for you super fast no special trips to
the doctor you can book online or you
know you can just go in literally the
same day you can even save yourself a
trip and schedule your covid-19 and flu
vaccines for the same time Steph and I
both take vaccinations seriously we have
a child who needs us to stay healthy we
do a lot of travel to see you guys and
speak at events we do our best to spend
time with family at the holidays and all
of those things mean that we need to
stay as responsible as we can in order
to keep ourselves safe case in point
just a few weeks ago our entire team
came out to North Carolina to work
together in the same room for the first
time since covid there was a lot of
hugging a lot of jumping up and down and
then a lot more hugging honestly for a
bunch of introverts team theorist is
shockingly close but you know what made
all of those close hugs possible
scientifically tested vaccines and
Walgreens makes it easy to access those
vaccines quickly reliably and
professionally so go get your
vaccinations now my friends that way by
the time you hit the relative's house
gift swaps or uncomfortable corporate
mandated holiday parties you're
confident in your health and your safety
schedule an appointment online today at
walgreens.com schedule vaccine again
that's walgreens.com schedule vaccine or
you know you can just click the link in
the description if you don't want to
type all of that stuff out be smart and
safe this holiday season loyal theorists
once again thank you to Walgreens for
sponsoring that portion of the video
Let's just jump back into the mystery of
Iris to decode what all of it means
starting with the last question first
who is Echo out of all the entities that
interact with Chase this character seems
to be the most benevolent it wants to
help wait where are you how can I hear
you
can you get me out of here no no no no
no no don't say that if both of us work
together we can get out of here when
Echo first appears the Iris camera
encounters some interference and you can
even see the silhouette of some sort of
figure in there easy money would say
that that is Echo but something else you
might not notice here is that all
throughout the rest of the interaction
the camera feed is glitchy with Chase
jumping around a fair bit now this could
certainly be a way to hide cuts to
different takes but it could also be a
hint as to the identity of echo in the
live stream one of the rooms that we see
appears to be some sort of Iris employee
break room and one of the posters on the
wall reads quote did you know alter 5914
is a Time Thief don't be like alter 5914
so since we're seeing some jumps in
Chase's conversation here with Echo
maybe Echo is Alter 5914 an entity who's
somehow able to manipulate time and the
glitches we're seeing aren't actually
glitches but rather time that's
literally being stolen by Echo
additionally if we look at the iris
Twitter feed we can see that some form
of time manipulation does exist inside
this universe according to this post
about the retrowave a microwave that
rewinds old meals back in time to when
they were fresh Iris started
experimenting with time manipulation
technology in the 40s so we know that it
is possible within this universe that
alone would be an interesting factoid
but that's not all we hear about time
travel in the series one other post from
the iris Twitter got my theorist senses
working quote again if you were able to
travel back in time and talk to yourself
what would you tell them what if Echo is
Chase from the future somehow traveling
back in time to communicate and tell
chase that he's special that he has a
big role to play in this story and that
it can help because again it's him from
the future it would be quite literally
an echo of events yet to come now
admittedly that sounds like a big shot
in the dark but it would help a lot of
things in the series make more sense for
example despite Iris assuring chase that
he's never been in the facility before
he insists that he somehow remembers it
this building is familiar it's like I've
been here before Mr Brody I assure you
that you've never been to this facility
before no it's it's not like that
there's an energy here that I've before
Sean also explained in his post-stream
breakdown that Deja Vu is a scientific
thing within this universe it means
something so in this world in this
universe Deja Vu has an explanation it's
there's like a scientific logic to why
that happens but
I'll never tell what if the deja vu is
chased picking up bits of his own
memories memories that he hasn't made
yet because they're Echoes memories that
would explain why Iris seems so
interested in his feelings on the
subject that's probably just Deja Vu or
something have you experienced other
instances of this like what what do you
mean my feelings like deja vu like
something's happened before and time
travel might not be the only dimensional
technology that iris is messing with
here I believe that a Multiverse of some
sort also exists in this world in
another Twitter post Iris asks quote
people only say reach for the stars
because they think it's impossible to do
so what if we reached even further the
only thing I can think of that's further
than the stars in outer space are places
outside of our universe in other
universes it might seem outlandish but
teleporting is established as a fairly
regular occurrence amongst these
characters we've already talked about
how Chase teleported to the top of a
parking garage at the end of one of his
videos but he's far from the only person
to experience this first of all Dr
schneepelstein Sean's wacky doctor
character witnesses an interdimensional
portal through one of his computer
monitors at the end of a 20 2019 video
that same portal is seen alongside the
magician character Marvin the
magnificent in a vision from a 2020
upload it's worth noting that both
antisepticeye and Chase are also seen in
that Vision showing that all of these
characters are indeed connected in some
way in fact antisepticeye himself has
already directly interacted with both Dr
schneppelstein as well as another
character in the roster the silent film
performer Jameson Jackson what if all of
these characters are literally the same
character just from different universes
different timelines and what's more Iris
clearly has an interest in these alter
egos with several of them likely already
in containment within the facility
during the original live stream we were
able to see Jameson's bow tie Marvin's
mask and several Jackie boyman Comics
hidden throughout the facility were
these just Easter eggs to Sean's other
characters or could these characters
actually be kept in the facility my
hunch is that they're here for a reason
and if Iris has an interest in all of
these other egos then of course they'd
want to capture antisepticeye too gotta
be a completionist of the decks and all
that that chase is Alter 11 4209 we've
been tracking him for quite some time
but why why would Iris be so interested
in collecting all these random
characters from across time and space
according to Aaron iris is a benevolent
organization that's just trying to
protect people so you see Chase Iris
helped those people in that Village we
saved them we find items like those and
we protect people from them we're not
here to harm you we just want to help
but this frankly does not align with
everything else that we see with Iris in
the series first of all their treatment
of Chase's borderline torture to the
point that they even make it difficult
for him to sleep you at least turn the
lights off thank you
and despite already knowing the answers
to the questions that they're asking to
chase they decide to push him to the
edge in a way that triggers horrible
repressed memories have you ever
experienced a terrible occurrence that
has impacted you significantly notice
the flashing images that appear here
Graves bodies a wedding rings Chase's
family the ones that died most likely at
the hands of antisepticeye and the more
they question chase the more they poke
and prod at his tragic past the closer
antisepticeye comes Iris knows this and
chooses to proceed anyway subject's
exposure has increased to concerning
levels just moving to second phase
pending board permission they want
antisepticeye to show up they want him
here but why what could they possibly
have to gain from this super dangerous
being it can't be for the good of the
universe can it to contain him no loyal
theorists they're doing it to harness
the power that antiseptic eye holds
despite this series taking place
basically in the present day it is
October 18th 2019. IRS has access to
technology that's far beyond what we
have in our universe on their social
media page they talk about true high
definition TV in the 1970s implants that
make you smarter microwaves that can
reverse time on specific objects and
Quantum displacers that can change the
mass of objects however the piece of
tech that we get the most elaborate
explanation for is their Watcher
security system these security cameras
have incredibly High 12K resolution they
can detect both the physical health and
emotional state of the people they
record and most importantly to our
purposes today they're Wireless and
batteryless thanks to an anti-matter
power source yeah Iris apparently has
anti-matter technology in the year 2019.
for proof look no further than that
Marvin the Magnificent video that I
mentioned earlier in it we get a
close-up of a spell book and what's that
written inside Iris equals anti-matter
this is from a video that was uploaded
back in 2020 so Sean's been laying the
groundwork for years now to my knowledge
this is also the first time that Iris
was officially used in the context of
this ongoing character narrative though
if I'm wrong on that feel free to call
me out in the comments but now we fast
forward ahead to the more recent Iris
project upload in particular one shot of
the iris facility from the original live
stream in it we see what appears to be a
pair of giant sci-fi power generators
you wouldn't be surprised if these
puppies were running on anti-matter and
suddenly with all this information
everything starts to make sense during
the live stream we saw a room that
seemed to be designed to contain a
powerful humanoid someone like
antisepticeye and while it's certainly a
bit on the nose the fact that the people
clearly trying to summon anti-septiceye
have themselves super futuristic
technology that's powered by anti-matter
yeah coincidence I think not iris is
trying to capture anti and then use him
as a power source and so they're
triggering Chase poking a sleeping
Dragon to get antisepticeye's attention
and uh well that didn't turn out well
for him it's interesting this entire
project plays with the idea of how toxic
social media can be how people who have
no real stake in something want to get
involved with the personal lives of
people that they don't even know Sean
explained as much during his live stream
everyone online always has to have an
opinion about everything all the time in
this way the viewers playing the game on
the iris live stream and the iris
Corporation within the story are
representative of people attempting to
insert themselves into businesses that
aren't really theirs they're pressing
people's buttons they're poking and
prodding all in hopes of getting a
reaction and things don't end up going
well for him again as Sean says
consequences can happen to things that
you didn't intend but it's too late to
kind of take any of it back in Universe
iris seems to be doing this for selfish
reasons to capture antisepticeye to use
him as a power source for their
futuristic technology and we as an
audience are also doing it selfishly to
get to the next part of the story to
learn more about the people we follow
online to the point where we probably
shouldn't regardless of whether I'm
right or wrong about this story Sean's
trying to tell here and the lore of the
world that he's building I just want to
take a step back and congratulate him on
creating a universe that's so ambitious
and one that's so far outside of his
normal content including going so far as
to make one of the coolest interactive
live events I've ever seen happen on
YouTube for real a clap and a half to
Sean and all the developers at hyper RPG
for putting that one together you know
that I'm a big fan of content creators
trying new things on their channels and
pushing the limits of their creativity
so you can bet I'm excited to see where
this one is going to be headed next so
as always my friend friends in the
meantime remember
[Music]
did you really just say and glue as in
you're just looking for the opposite of
and cut
yeah no see this this right here is why
we can't have any good lore for the
channels all right sorry
[Music]
[Music]